do you guys have a timeline are you
talking about expanding the family yeah
I mean we don't have a specific timeline
but we're definitely getting tonight
right after this event the timeline yes
we are going to start trying right over
a bad time to try you never know yeah if
it happens it happens and we're we're
just right now we're just focused on all
this but I'm sure our attention will
shift that way
that was less than two months ago but
now et has learned Brody Jenner and
Kaitlin Carter have called it quits
their reps tell et in a statement quote
they love and respect one another and
know that this is the best decision for
their relationship moving forward
sourced lzt quote the couple had been
having problems for some time as it
turns out the pair was never legally
married though on the hills new
beginnings they talked about how upset
Brody was that his dad also named
Caitlyn missed their lavish 2018
ceremony in Bali
Brody really just kind of brushed it off
but he has to have felt something but he
doesn't express it not having my dad at
the wedding was it was it was a bummer I
would have loved to have had her there
but she had better things to do
apparently starting a family was also a
storyline for Brody and Kaitlynn on the
show and his mom Linda Thompson was all
about it trying to fatten Kaitlyn up so
she can get her BMI index up Jeff I have
that baby I mean no pressure but you
know I told you I was 31 when I had you
and 33 when I had Brody but my life
circumstance has been crazy